aegon the unworthy legitimized all his
bastards on his deathbed
inevitably the greatest of these damon
blackfire declared himself the rightful
heir and ignited yet another war for the
crown
after much bloodshed damon was killed by
an alliance of his half-brothers on the
red grass field
all the same his descendants continued
to threaten the targaryens until half a
century later when barristan the bold
slew mailers the monstrous on the
stepstones extinguishing damon's line
aegon the fourth of his name is
remembered by history as the unworthy
quite defeat considering the other kings
of westeros but even in a family not
known for equanimity
aegon stands out for spiteful
incompetence
he tore apart the realm simply because
he couldn't rule himself much less
westeros
as a young prince aegon's wit made him
beloved at court and won him forgiveness
for youthful indiscretions but the cold
steel of the iron throne didn't temper
his passions king aegon proclaimed that
if he had to spend his days being
pricked by a thousand swords he'd spend
his nights pricking others with his one
lord sent the daughters from court so
they would not catch the king's eye
whilst other lords summoned the
daughters to court
so they would
the only woman in whom he took no
pleasure was his sister and wife nares
even after she gave him a son and air
deron perhaps aegon was jealous of her
supposed love for his brother the
legendary hero prince eamon the dragon
knight
aegon was most certainly jealous of him
not of his bravery or honor but how
young maidens swooned an old cried at
the songs about him
but most likely aegon disregarded his
wife and son because he chafed at
restraints of any kind be they the bonds
of marriage or patrimony or even reason
when prince daeron objected to his
father's foolish plan to invade dawn
aegon incited a lickspittle lord to
accuse the queen of adultery with aemon
making daeron illegitimate
prince aemon defended the queen's honor
in trial by combat
but while the lord's claim publicly died
with him no sword can kill a rumor
out of spite and peak aegon had seeded
out into his own heirs claimed to the
throne
which bore bitter fruit with the birth
of another son
the bastard damon waters by the king's
own cousin
raised in the red keep on account of his
mother's royal blood damon grew tall and
powerful and excelled at all the martial
skills that men wrongly value in leaders
instead of protecting his own heir from
arrival
aegon knighted damon at 12 and shocked
the realm by bestowing on him the
conqueror's own valyrian steel sword
he even let the boy renounce his common
bastard's name and take the targaryen
sword's name for his own becoming damon
blackfire
still though a name can change blood
can't and deron was aegon's only true
born son
until he wasn't
on his deathbed aegon forever earned his
epithet by legitimizing all his bastards
from the baseborne sons of
to the great bastards of noble ladies
including damon
fittingly aegon's last act was to thrust
himself into the realm
and seed chaos
a targaryen without self-restraint may
have led westeros to the brink of ruin
but the highborn pushed it over
though daeron governed justly and wisely
correcting the worst excesses of his
father's rule many lords had grown rich
off these excesses and did not approve
of deron's reforms particularly the
peace he struck with dawn the
malcontents rallied to daemon and
whispered that he should be king instead
of his brother whom thanks to aegon many
suspected was a bastard at first damon
indulged these lords out of courtesy and
vanity but over time their grievances
and flattery wore down his objections
along with any sense of obligation to
the half-brother who had granted him
lands and a wife
daemon agreed to claim the throne by
right of birth
and more importantly arms
a wheel with two hubs will not turn and
a kingdom with two kings will burn as
the saying goes not that such a cast
ever stopped anyone with even the
remotest claim and opportunity much less
house a black fire
their rebellions consumed tens of years
and thousands of lives
first damon's own
then his son damon ii who reigned for a
night
then another son hagon crowned by
bittersteel another legitimized great
bastard who had founded the golden
company to support the blackfyre claim
when aegon was executed bittersteel
crowned hagan's eldest son damon iii who
in turn was slain by their lord
commander of the kingsguard sir duncan
the tall
finally maley's the monstrous fell to
sir barristan selmy in the war of the
nine penny kings and the blackfy
rebellion ended with the extinction of
the entire line
as is appropriate fire is only black
when it is burned to ash
perhaps that was the true problem with
the targaryens
the blood of the dragon runs hot and
fire consumes
perhaps what westeros needs is a ruler
born not from fire
but from snow
aegon targaryens blackfyre and visenya's
dark sister disappeared in damon
blackfire's rebellion
a simple word for a simple act
and so of course men complicate it
a child born to a wife is a gift from
the gods a child born to a mistress or
an obedient serving girl is a bastard
unworthy of its father's name
so instead we call the children after
the land where they were born
flowers in the rich and hill in the
westerlands
stone in the vale and storm in the
stormlands
rivers in the riverlands and waters in
the groundlands
pike in the iron islands snow in the
north and in dorne sand
by these names everyone can recognize a
bastard
even if his own father won't
though sometimes a father with too much
gold and daughters will ask the king to
legitimize a bastard son and give him
his family name
if his wife objects the next one does
not
but sometimes the gods play their jokes
and later his wife will give him a true
born son of their own
when this happens
well
children die all the time
so do fathers
even the beautiful targaryens had
bastards when brothers tired of their
sisters
many took the name blackfyre after the
conqueror's own sword
when aegon the unworthy legitimized all
his bastards on his deathbed they rose
up against his true born heir westeros
bled
dorne
yawned
for most of westeros the blackfyre
rebellion only proved what they already
knew
bastards are treacherous born of lust
and shame
but here in dorne
lust is not shameful
we know that bastardy does not make a
man more treacherous than another
man does not need the help
most boys dream of becoming a kingsguard
rich boys from good families get a
chance
smart boys stay at home and sing songs
about them instead opening purses and
thighs because the kingsguard isn't
really good for much else
prince aemon the dragon knight may be
the most famous kingsguard who ever
lived
how did he die
defending aegon the unworthy from the
brothers of a man whom aegon fed to his
dogs the man's crime
sleeping with one of the many mistresses
aegon wasn't using
and the man was one of aegon's own
king's guard
prince eamon the dragon knight who
wielded the valyrian sword dark sister
he died defending king aegon the
unworthy from assassins though the king
had insulted ayman throughout his reign
and had well earned his fate
because prince eamonn had sworn out oath
beside the name of sir wayne corbery who
dueled a targaryen bastard damon
blackfire for an hour during the battle
of the red grass field though outmatched
and grievously wounded because
sir queen had sworn out of
but even without our dragons we were
still the blood of old valyria
which proved just as dangerous
one of my foolish ancestors didn't see
what separated his bastards from our
family proper and legitimized them all
on his deathbed
adopting the name blackfyre the bastards
proved their nature
and tried to seize their father's
kingdom
and when they failed their sons tried
when the sons failed their grandsons
tried until finally sarbarist barristan
the bold knight of the kingsguard slew
melees the monstrous in the war of the
nine penny kings
ending the last of the blackfyre line
ultimately without our dragons and with
our blood diluted by commoners we fail
to see the greatest threat growing under
our noses